[Music]
this morning the bald eagle the
improbable journey of america's bird a
new book by pulitzer prize-winning
author jack e davis tells an epic tale
first celebrated then almost wiped out
twice
the number of bald eagles soaring in
this country is now higher than ever
it's a story of ruin
and redemption but the latest chapter
is still being written
[Music]
there is almost nothing as striking as
watching a bald eagle successfully make
its morning catch
a bird native only to this continent
long revered by native americans it
seemed like the natural choice to
represent the united states on its great
seal in 1776
but it was not easy to get there
ben franklin proposed a seal with moses
thomas jefferson also a biblical image
john adams suggested a picture of
hercules
until the eagle found its proper place
in 1782
how does an eagle choose its home it
chooses home
it's all about geography it's about
location location location they want to
be near food
they want a tree that has some height to
it jack davis is the author of the bald
eagle the improbable journey of
america's bird are they called bald
eagles i mean because they're like me
the ball because or is there it's i mean
some people feel there's a little more
to it
yeah so i write about this in the book
and bald also can mean you know brazen
you know and refer to the bald eagles
behavior
early resistance to the bald eagle being
our nation's symbol was led in part by
some who felt the eagle was too eager to
steal the spoils of others that included
the most famous naturalist of all john
james audubon
it's a sad story but he loathed the bald
eagle he truly did not think it should
be a symbol of the united states
he saw saw it as a coward as a thief as
a scavenger beneath the integrity of the
united states
and he truly wanted the turkey to be the
country's bird
mixed feelings toward bald eagles led to
their near decimation in the 1800s
it was a predator animal and like wolves
and bears and coyotes it was to be
eradicated to protect livestock but
there were all these myths about bald
eagles being able to carry away
livestock that were far too heavy for
them
ornithologists perpetuating those myths
and mothers are warned
not to leave their babies outside
unattended
lest a bald eagle come along and fly
away with it depictions in popular
culture included this 1908 thomas edison
film rescued from an eagle's nest
protection against unchecked hunting
eventually arrived
until in the next century a new threat
ddt the once popular insecticide
by the time ddt was finally banned in
1972
eagles were almost gone
today however thanks to conservation and
cleaner water
bald eagles are soaring higher than ever
the population in the lower 48 states
has quadrupled in the last 13 years
20 years ago in this neighborhood would
you have ever seen this
probably not
shawn lee breeding leads the eagle watch
project at the audubon center for birds
of prey in maitland florida monitoring
the 1500 plus nesting bald eagle pairs
in the states the highest concentration
in the u.s outside alaska
including many now living in residential
neighborhoods is all the eagles
in the country now and on cell towers a
good thing or a challenging thing what
is it
it's a bit of both i mean for
conservationists it's great you know
it's like the great success story that
we all love to tell that when you take
steps to protect a species you really
can make a difference but you know as
their population increases you can get
issues
you know with cell tower nest if the
cell tower company needs to do
maintenance they can't go up on the
tower while there's eagles nesting at
the center for birds of prey
they do everything they can to help the
increasing number of bald eagles making
dangerous human contact what we do first
is we'll hood them and that helps calm
them down because they're extremely
stressed right now this one suffered a
devastating wing injury after a possible
power line collision so right now it's
in the height of eagle season we'll see
so um
he's extremely injured
some don't make it
ready
but over 600 bald eagles have been
successfully rehabilitated and released
others may be found with a birth defect
that makes it possible to survive but
not in the wild i'll tell you what it's
one thing seeing them half a mile away
it's a whole nother to
be this close tell me about it i still
pinch myself that this is something i
have the opportunity to do like trouble
born with a misaligned beak
here with volunteer and teacher maggie
haynes so he came here and he had some
surgeries
he had his jaw wire shut even at one
point and that's kind of where he got
his name trouble because he had to have
fish slushies and if you would imagine
how you would make that that's exactly
what it is
and he had to be tube fed and so his
life started out really tough but he got
the nickname trouble
a couple hours away jack davis took us
to the three lakes wildlife management
area if i'm an eagle i'm choosing here i
think over the cell phone tower in the
middle of the residential neighborhood
[Music]
this nest is situated just a half mile
from an abundant lake
with a mom and dad raising two little
guys they make for life and they come
back to the same nest every year the
couple does and every year they build
onto the nest
as long as that tree lasts and the storm
doesn't blow the nest down or the tree
down that nest can exist for 20 30 40
years
here
we kept our distance
as more of us will likely have to do in
the future
if we want america's bird to keep flying
oh so high
[Music]
when we
reflect on our environmental past in
this country
we tend to focus on the the grim and the
tragic to the point that i think we've
gone too far and i wanted to write a
positive story one that um was uplifting
what threats do bald eagles still face
today unfortunately they still were
their only threat
it's a bird that steals into our
consciousness and we're not going to let
it go
[Music]
so you can now find bald eagles in every
state in the lower 48 and alaska where
there's more than anywhere else and i
asked them i said what if you want to
help protect eagles or make sure they
continue to thrive in the future i said
what was the one thing you'd say and she
said to me she said don't throw trash
out your car window when you're driving
because they go to get it by the side of
the road and then a lot of eagles get
hit oh wow on the road that was the that
was the one piece of advice there are a
lot of reasons not to do this but
there's another plenty of other things
you can do as well but the success story
is just i mean quadrupling yeah in
population in the lower 48 in the last
13 years is pretty remarkable i just
learned so much
it was beautiful but also not knowing
that nobody wanted them right as a
symbol twice a turkey over an eagle yeah
come on that was great jeff yeah very
nicely